so it's a task being described as a
challenge for Generations rebuilding
Ukraine after Russia's Invasion EU
leaders are meeting in Germany to lay
out what's being called a new Marshall
Plan Germany's chancellor says the
Reconstruction will require combined
International strength it's estimated
will cost at least 200 billion dollars
to repair the infrastructure Muhammad
jamjum is joining us from Kiev to talk
to us about the damage to infrastructure
that you've been seeing in ki Muhammad
sure let me just first address Doreen
what we've heard today from the
Ukrainian president from below de
mirzalinski he spoke virtually to that
conference dedicated to the
Reconstruction of Ukraine in Berlin and
and he said that there should be a legal
and concrete mechanism for compensating
for losses suffered by Ukraine at the
expense of Russian Assets Now as far as
what we've seen here you know you don't
have to go too far outside of the
capital where we are to experience just
what the fighting has done to this
country we went uh just a couple of days
ago to the city of irpin that's just
outside of Kiev it's in the key region
um and that's where there was very heavy
fighting in the early days of the war it
stands as a symbol of Ukrainian
resistance because you had them
repelling Russian advances and Russian
forces eventually withdrew from that
area but what we saw there Doreen was
shocking months after Russian forces
withdrew you had apartment blocks that
were still lying in ruin where no
Reconstruction had taken place to the
point that you have the building
ownership Association they put signs on
the side of the building asking for
private donations and providing Bank
details for those who wish to donate in
the city of irpin just one example in
this country you have over a thousand
buildings that were damaged as a result
of the fighting you have over a hundred
that were destroyed completely so that's
just a snapshot of where things are in
this country now the Kiev School of
Economics just in September estimated
that it would take at least 200 billion
dollars to begin to repair the damage to
this country's infrastructure the reason
I bring that up is because that was
before this recent wave of massive
attacks by Russia that started on
October 10th missiles and such targeting
critical infrastructure throughout the
country and especially the power grid up
to 30 to 40 percent of the power grid
has been heavily damaged in these
attacks attacks by missile attacks by
drone over the course of the past couple
of weeks I spoke in the last couple of
hours to the president of the keep
School of Economics he says he estimates
now the toll as far as how much it would
take to try to start rebuilding the
infrastructure in this country would be
perhaps around
240 billion dollars so that just goes to
show how much worse it's getting this is
at a time when temperatures are dropping
when there are concerns about the
electricity and winter approaching
because the power grid has been so
damaged and people are really worried
about what's going to happen to them
going forward and they're really
concerned that Russia is going to try to
weaponize the winter all right thank you
so much Muhammad reporting from Kiev